Well, good morning everyone,
and happy Labor Day weekend to you.
My name is Aaron Ferguson.
I'm one of the elders here at Henderson Hills,
and we are so glad that you are here today.
Uh, labor Day, fun fact for you.
There's over 160 countries in the world
that celebrate Labor Day.
Uh, not every nation does, of course, but most of them.
Egypt, for example, does not celebrate Labor Day.
Everyone in Egypt works on Labor Day from the top down,
which sounds kinda like a pyramid scheme to me,
but don't judge me.
Uh, we're so glad that you're here today.
I have a special assignment today
and my job is to look one more time at first Samuel
before we start a series next week on Second Samuel.
Now, John has given me
31 chapters to go over in 35 minutes.
He got to do this 29th and 29 sermons.
So you're gonna have to put your seatbelt on.
We're gonna have to hustle through today.
Thank you John Wilmuth.
But we'll get to that in just a minute.
All 29 sermons are on our church website.
If you missed one of those,
you can go there and, uh, look at that.
This is a fantastic Old Testament book
that we're gonna review today.
So hope you have your Bibles.
We're gonna dive in and, uh,
cover quite a bit of ground very quickly.
Now, if you're anything like my students,
when I say let's review, they kind of roll their eyes
and slip into a coma, but don't do that this morning, okay?
Don't. If you're one of those that pushes,
skip the recap on the Netflix show.
Resist the urge this morning,
and, uh, I think you'll enjoy what we're about to cover.
Besides, I binged watched all 19 hours
of the First Samuel series for you.
Now, I was asleep for about eight hours of it,
but that's okay.
We won't talk about that. So turn with me
to Judges chapter 21.
Let's jump right in to our study.
While you're turning there, I want
to give you some basics on the book of First Samuel.
Did you know the books of First
and second Samuel are actually one book originally
and later translators separated them
for organization and simplicity.
So we get the two books today, but they used to be one,
and though the books are named
after Samuel, there's actually, we believe three authors,
one Chronicles 29 29 tells us, mentions three guys, Samuel,
of course, and then two prophets, Nathan and Gad.
So why are the books named after Samuel? Good question.
Well, he's the one that anoints the first two kings
of Israel, and so they give him the credit
for these two books.
So there you go. There's some basics about the Book
of one Samuel.
Today I want to answer three questions.
What is one Samuel all about? What happens in the book?
Uh, what are some of the major themes in the book
and what is the big picture of the book?
What are we supposed to take away from
our study of one Samuel?
So let's do that answer.
Question number one, what happens in one Samuel?
Join me in judges 2125.
To understand one Samuel, we've got to begin here.
In those days, there was no king in Israel.
Everyone did what was right in his own eyes. Okay?
Why is that verse important?
Well, before one Samuel, there were no kings, only judges.
After one Samuel, there are kings.
So what happens in one Samuel, they transition from judges
to kings.
Okay, we can all go home now.
Now there's a little more to it than that,
but that's a good start.
Before one Samuel, you had judges, and
after one Samuel, we have kings.
Uh, during the period of judges, the people
of God had his laws,
and if they obeyed his laws, he blessed them.
If, if they disobeyed, he kind of removed his blessing
and they were conquered by some neighboring tribe,
and then they would repent
and God would send a, a, deliver a judge
who would rescue them.
And they repeat this cycle multiple times
in the period of judges.
So in those days, things were very chaotic.
Now let's go to one Samuel.
We'll spend the rest of the morning in one Samuel.
Let jump with me to chapter four, one Samuel chapter four.
We are gonna jump right into that chaos.
I was just talking about Israel's at
war with the Philistines.
There two of their priests, HNI
and Phineas lead everybody out to war.
Unadvised take the arc of the covenant with them,
not a good decision and disaster strikes.
So join me one Samuel chapter four, verse 17.
One of the guys escapes comes back
and talks to Eli, the high priest.
He who brought the news answered
and said to Eli, Israel has fled before the Philistines,
and there has been a, a great defeat among the people.
And your two sons, Eli Hni and Phineas are dead.
And the Ark of God
or the Ark of the Covenant has been captured.
And as soon as he mentioned the Ark of God,
Eli fell over backward from his seat by the side
of the gate, and his neck was broken and he died.
For the man was old and heavy,
and he had judged Israel for 40 years.
Israel's defeated in battle the Ark of the Covenant stolen.
Oh, by the way, HNE and Phineas are dead, and Eli falls over
and, and he's out too.
So something's happening right here at the beginning
of one Samuel.
And what we have is sort of a new era coming in.
God is at work. Skip on down to verse 21.
Eli's daughter-in-law was pregnant.
She names the child, IBA, which means no glory,
saying the glory has departed from Israel
because the arc of God has been captured and
because of her father-in-law and her husband.
In verse 22, she says, the glory has departed from Israel.
The arc of God has been captured.
Now, this is one of the lowest moments in Israel's history,
and it's into this setting
that Samuel is born and raised.
Now Samuel's gonna be the last judge of Israel.
He is gonna anoint the first kings
and transition Israel into a monarchy.
What did they have before they had a monarchy?
When a king is in charge, they actually had a theocracy,
a theocracy, theo meaning God rules.
God was ruling them directly,
but they are going to reject God as king
and they're gonna ask for a human king.
So join me in one Samuel eight.
Let's skip ahead a little bit.
One Samuel chapter eight
and verse four, all the elders
of Israel gathered together came to Samuel at Rama
and said to him, behold, you are old
and your sons do not walk in your ways.
Now, a point for us, a king
to judge us like all the nations.
But the thing displeased Samuel, when they said,
give us a king to judge us.
And Samuel prayed to the Lord.
In verse seven, the Lord said to Samuel, obey the voice
of the people in all that they say to you,
for they have not rejected you,
but they have rejected me from being king over them.
There you can see the theocracy God ruling.
So Israel rejects God as king. They, they want a human king.
They wanna be like all the other nations around them.
Samuel says, that's not a good idea.
And he warns them about the abuse of kings.
The people don't listen. They insist on having a king.
And so God leads Samuel to Saul.
Join me next chapter, chapter nine,
in verse 17, chapter nine,
and verse 17, when Samuel saw Saul,
the Lord told him, here's the man of whom I spoke to you.
It is he who shall restrain my people. Okay?
So the Lord led Samuel to the first king Saul.
Turn the page to chapter 10, verse 24.
Samuel introduces Saul to the people.
Samuel said to all the people,
do you see him whom the Lord has chosen?
There's none like him among all the people.
And all the people shouted, long live the king.
So here we go. We now have a human king named Saul.
Now Saul has some success, but it doesn't last very long.
Why? Because he gets off track pretty quickly.
He disobeys some of God's commands
and he's gonna lose the kingdom as a result.
Skip ahead to one Samuel chapter 13,
one Samuel chapter 13, verse 13, Samuel says
to Saul, the Saul has disobeyed.
You have done foolishly.
You've not kept the command of the Lord your God,
which he commanded you for.
Then the Lord would've established your
kingdom over Israel forever.
But now your kingdom shall not continue.
And the Lord has sought out a man
after his own heart that's David.
And the Lord commanded him to be prince over his people
because you have not kept what the Lord commanded you.
So God took the kingdom away from Saul, gives it to David,
and let's skip ahead into chapter 16.
Where does that happen? Chapter 16, verse 12.
And he, Samuel sent
and brought him David in.
He was ruddy, he had beautiful eyes, was handsome,
and the Lord said, arise, anoint him, David, for this is he,
Samuel took the horn of oil
and anointed him in the midst of his brothers.
And the spirit of the Lord rushed upon David from
that day forward.
Now, this is a very odd situation.
You have a king sitting on the throne
and now you have, his successor has already been anointed.
So this is gonna cost some tension in their relationship.
At first, Saul and David were friends.
Uh, David served in Saul's court
and married Saul's daughter
and was best friends with his son.
But then everything fell apart when David defeated Goliath
and the Philistines, Saul became jealous.
Uh, the women sung Saul has killed his thousands
and David his 10 thousands, right?
Look, with with me at, uh, chapter 18,
everything turns in their relationship.
Chapter 18, verse eight, Saul was very angry.
This saying displeased him, he said, they have ascribed
to David 10,000 and to me, thousands.
What more can he have? But the kingdom
and Saul ied David, from that day on,
he was suspicious of David.
From that day on for the rest of the book, chapters 18
to 31, Saul pursues David tries to kill him,
and David literally goes on the run until Saul dies
in battle in chapter 31.
So Israel's monarchy is off to a rocky start.
Saul's administration is a disaster.
The Philistines defeat Israel.
They're no better off than they were
before they had a human king.
They're no better off than they were,
than in the period of judges.
So that's the book of one Samuel.
There's a whole lot of other plots and subplots,
but you get the gist here of what happened.
Now that Saul is dead, we're gonna open up next week,
second Samuel and David is gonna be king,
and we'll take off, uh, from there with our new series.
Okay, second question.
What are we supposed to take from a book like one Samuel?
What are the major themes?
What are we be looking for in the book of one Samuel?
Well, I have chosen four this morning, four major themes,
and when you put them together, they make a big picture.
And we'll see that picture here in just a minute.
Let's talk about the four themes. First, four themes.
Now, this obviously probably more than four,
but here's the four that I jump out at me.
Theme number one in one Samuel is kings. Kings.
No surprise there. Israel transitioned from
judges two kings.
Now, some 500 years earlier though,
God told Abraham that his descendants would produce kings.
Listen to Genesis 17, six.
God said to Abraham, I'll make you exceedingly fruitful
and I'll make you into nations
and kings shall come from you.
The partial fulfillment of
that prophecy happens here in one Samuel.
We get Saul, we get David, and I say partial fulfillment
because there's more to come, which we'll get
to later in just a minute.
Israel thought having a human king would
answer all their problems.
But the problem is human kings are just as flawed as we are.
And so there's trouble.
Only God is a perfect king
who can reign in justice and wisdom.
Human leaders will always disappoint.
But that's the first theme in one Samuel is kings.
How about the second theme?
The second theme in one Samuel is obedience. Obedience.
Turn with me to chapter 15.
Chapter 15, right in the middle
of one Samuel is the turning point of the book.
God expected obedience from everyone in the story.
His people, his priests, and his kings.
If they obeyed God, he blessed them.
If they didn't obey God, he removes their the blessing.
And the turning point comes when Saul Disobeys God,
chapter 15, verse 22, Samuel says to
Saul, has the Lord as great delight in burnt offerings
and sacrifices as in obeying the voice of the Lord.
Behold, to obey is better than sacrifice.
Go on to the end of 23
because you, Saul have rejected the word of the Lord.
You've disobeyed.
He has also rejected you from becoming king
or from being King.
Saul's success is king,
was dependent on whether he was obedient to God.
Now, God is speaking to Saul here in this passage,
but in a larger sense, he's speaking
to the whole nation of Israel.
Obedience matters to God.
And even in a larger sense, he's speaking to us today.
Jesus said in John 14, if you love me,
you will keep my commandments.
Obedience matters even in the New Testament.
So obedience matters to God, but Saul was disobedient
and he's gonna lose the kingdom.
So theme number one, kings theme number two is obedience.
How about theme number three?
Theme number three is the sovereignty of God.
The sovereignty of God.
Don't be scared of the word sovereignty.
It just means power of God, authority of God.
He's in charge, he's in control.
Turn with me to chapter two, back at the beginning
of the book.
You know, when we identify characters of this book,
several people come to mind.
Eli, the high priest, Samuel, the last judge, Saul,
Jonathan, David, even Hannah, who prays for a son.
There's lots of characters here,
but the main character in the story is none of those people.
It's God. God is the main character of one Samuel.
He's the one directing the action.
Look with me at the prayer. Hannah's praying for a son.
Look at chapter two, verse seven.
She says, the Lord makes poor and makes rich.
He brings low and he exalts.
He raises up the pore from the dust.
He lifts the needy from the ash heap to make them sit
with princes and inherit a seat of honor.
For the pillars of the earth are the Lords.
And on them, he has set the world.
Hannah recognizes God's sovereignty.
He's the one that's in control here.
He's the one that's in charge.
Now, where do we see God's sovereignty?
In the book of one Samuel?
Well, let me share a few things with you,
Hannah, at the very beginning.
Praise to the Lord for a child,
she recognizes God is the one who controls childbirth.
He's sovereign. God holds Eli, the high priest
and his sons accountable.
He's the judge holding Israel's spiritual
leaders accountable.
God handed over Israel
to the Philistines or the Philistines.
God protected the Ark of the Covenant when it was captured,
God gave Samuel permission to choose a king.
God kept King Saul accountable to obeying him.
God chose David as the second king.
And God protected David from Saul.
You know, we always tend to focus on the the main
characters, those who are on the stage.
But it's God who is working behind the scenes here.
He's the main character directing all the action.
So Hannah, Eli, Samuel, Saul, David, all had
to wait on the Lord for their directions.
He is sovereign. He is sovereign.
Now, God was sovereign then. And guess what?
He's sovereign today. Even in your life,
you might think you're in charge
of your life, but you're not.
He is. You might think at times, no one's in control.
Look at the chaos all around us. Someone's in control.
It's God. He's behind the scenes directing all things
to fulfill his purposes.
One of my favorite verses, Proverbs 16, nine,
we may plan our way,
but it's the Lord who directs our steps.
You can plan all day long,
but it's God who is behind the scenes.
He is sovereign. So theme number one, kings theme.
Number two, obedience theme. Number three, sovereignty.
Theme number four might not seem as obvious
as the other three, but this one really jumps out at me.
And that is the chase. The chase.
There are three chases in one Samuel.
What do I mean chase? Number one is Israel.
Israel was God's chosen nation set on earth to glorify him,
be different, be unique.
But instead of doing that, they wanted
to be like all the other nations.
They were chasing after the world.
They didn't wanna be different.
They wanted to be just like the world.
That's the first chase. Israel chased the world's likeness.
The second person that chases somebody is Saul,
probably the one you're thinking of.
God had chosen Saul to be the first king
of his chosen nation,
and his descendants could have been kings forever.
God says, but instead of doing what God wanted,
he spends all of his time chasing after David.
He's completely obsessed with chasing David
and even killing David.
He couldn't allow for somebody to be more loved
or more valuable than him.
So rather than focus on what God wanted, he's chasing David
and wasting his time.
Chase number three is David.
David Bible says he's a man after God's own heart.
He chases hard after the Lord.
In one Samuel, his relationship with the Lord,
especially trusts in him in ways no one else would.
You remember the story of Goliath?
Everybody's afraid of Goliath.
They see Goliath, they don't see God.
He shows up and he sees God and not Goliath.
There's something different about this guy.
He's chasing hard after the Lord.
He worships God when he is in the desert, getting chased
by Saul, he writes Psalms about the Lord.
Listen to Psalm 18. I love you, Lord.
My strength, the Lord is my rock, my fortress, my deliverer,
my God, my rock
and whom I take refuge, my shield, the horn
of my salvation, my stronghold.
I call upon the Lord who is worthy to be praised.
I'm saved from my enemies.
David was chasing the Lord.
The chase is your fourth theme.
Now let me stop right here and ask you a question.
Who are you chasing today?
Many of you might be chasing the world.
You wanna be like the world, rather than being indifferent.
You wanna blend in with the world.
You don't wanna stand out.
But the Bible tells us, do not be conformed to this world
and don't even love the world or the things of the world.
The world is passing away.
Why waste time trying to be like the world?
Some of you may be chasing the image
of others like Saul was.
You have fallen for the lie that others are more loved, more
valuable, more this, more that you look at others
as your standard of perfection.
You know, young people are being taken today
by this very thing.
Social media is the bar for the image today.
And if they are not liked and followed
and praised by an audience, they don't know what to do.
They're chasing after the image of others.
When we should be chasing after the Lord.
Like David, are you in God's word?
Are you listening to him trying
to discern his will for your life?
Are you trying to glorify him?
Wherever that takes you at work, at school,
in your neighborhood, wherever you go,
you're chasing the Lord.
Whatever it is for he wants for your life
and glorifying him.
And all you do, who are you chasing today?
What is consuming your time, your energy and your treasure?
Is it the world? Is it others? Is it the Lord?
Well, those are the four themes that I see in one Samuel.
Now let's put those four puzzle pieces together
and we start to see a big picture here in one Samuel,
and I'll wrap up with this today.
What is the big picture of one Samuel? It's pretty simple.
It's Christ. Jesus says himself.
Luke 24, all the Old Testament books
point to him.
So the big picture of any book in the Old Testament is
Christ, no matter what book you're reading,
Christ is the key to understanding it.
So we have to look at one Samuel with the lens
of the Messiah to come Jesus Christ
and ask ourselves, how does this book point to Christ?
So let's answer that question.
How does this book, first Samuel point to Christ?
Turn back with me to chapter two.
Let me show you some things in chapter two, Hannah,
when she's praying for a son, a child points
to Christ in her prayer.
Look at first Samuel two in verse 10.
Second half of verse 10,
the Lord will judge the ends of the earth.
She says He will give strength to his king
and exalt the horn of his anointed.
Now, is this a prophecy of Saul or David?
Could be partially,
but this is also a prophecy of the anointed,
the king that is to come.
Jesus Christ, she's pointing to Christ who is to come.
Look on down at uh, verse 35, God prophesied to Eli of a,
of a perfect priest to come someday.
In verse 35, I will raise up
for myself a faithful priest who shall do according to
what is in my heart and in my mind was that
answered in Samuel.
Partially it's gonna be ultimately fulfilled in Christ.
Samuel is actually a picture of Christ.
Think about it. He was dedicated to the Lord from birth.
He spends a whole lot of time in the house of God,
the tabernacle, and he was Israel's spiritual leader.
So he's a picture of Christ.
Listen to, uh, verse 26, if you're right there.
Go back to verse 26.
The boy Samuel continued to grow both in stature
and in favor with the Lord and also with man Jesus.
The same thing, instead of Jesus as a boy.
Luke 2 52, if you like to connect verses here, Luke 2 52,
Jesus grew in stature and wisdom
and in favor with God, in favor with man.
This is the Bible's way of linking Samuel to Christ.
He's a picture. He's a, he's a type of Christ. So is David.
David's a picture of Christ.
We're gonna see that in Second Samuel, okay?
But the real picture
of Christ is when we put those four themes together
and they start to fit like a puzzle.
So let's do that as we close today. Take those four themes.
How do we see Christ in those four themes?
Well, first in the theme of kings, the kings
of Israel are gonna foreshadow the greater king who is
to come, the Messiah Christ.
Listen to, uh, Isaiah chapter nine.
This is, uh, typically a passage we
read around Christmas time.
For to us, a child is born to us, a son is given,
and the government shall be upon his shoulder,
and his name shall be called wonderful counselor,
mighty God, everlasting father, prince of peace,
of the increase of his government and of his peace.
There will be no end on the throne of David
and over his kingdom to establish it, to uphold it
with justice and with righteousness.
From this time forth
and forevermore, Jesus is the king to come.
The kings in Israel
and one Samuel foreshadow the great king who is to come.
How about theme number two, obedience. Obedience.
Human kings, of course, are imperfect.
They do not obey perfectly.
But the king to come, the Messiah
will obey perfectly.
In fact, Christ obeyed his father all the way to the cross.
Philippians chapter two, verse eight, Paul says,
being found in human form, he Jesus humbled himself
by becoming obedient, even to the point of death.
Death on a cross.
Jesus was perfectly obedient to his father.
Hebrews chapter four, uh, the author
of Hebrews says, Jesus was obedient and never sinned.
He obeyed God perfectly.
So the theme of obedience
here is fulfilled in the Messiah, Jesus Christ.
How about that third theme, sovereignty.
Absolutely because of his obedience.
Jesus is given the name above all names.
And he even tells his disciples, Matthew 28,
all authority has been given in heaven
and on earth to me, he is sovereign.
He is the Lord of all.
And one day he will return to rule over his kingdom.
He shall reign.
That was our, our title for the series of one Samuel.
He Shall Reign. Okay, what about the fourth theme?
The chase. The chase.
Now, Jesus was more than just a man after God's own heart.
He was actually God in the flesh.
And he does something that Adam could not do, something
that Israel could not do, something that Saul
and David could not do.
He glorifies the Lord in a way no one else can do.
In fact, when he is baptized Matthew three,
God the Father says, this is my beloved son
and whom I am well pleased.
And Jesus, at the end of his life, John chapter 17 says,
I have glorified you
and everything I've done, I've accomplished
everything you sent me to do.
No one else has done this.
Not Adam, not Israel, not Saul, not David.
No one could glorify or chase
after the Lord like Jesus did.
So you put all four themes together
and they make a beautiful picture of Christ.
So guess what? Second Samuel's gonna be all about Christ.
We don't need to listen to the next series
because we know it's all about now.
I do ask you to come next week as we open up Second Samuel,
but we know ahead of time it's going to be about Christ.
So how do I recap First Samuel as we close,
it's the story of Israel's first kings
who fail miserably.
But it's also a story that foreshadows the king to come.
The Messiah, Jesus Christ, who obeys his father perfectly,
goes to the cross, dies for our sin,
is raised from the grave,
and he'll come back someday to reign again.
He shall reign. That is first Samuel.
So we are ready for Second Samuel next week.
Lemme close with just a few questions for you as we
enter into a time of prayer.
Who is your king this morning? Who is your king?
Is it you? Is it God?
Who's calling the shots in your life right now?
Who is it that you are obeying?
How are you doing at obeying the Lord?
Are you recognizing God's sovereignty in your life?
I can plan my way, but Lord direct my steps.
And who are you chasing today?
Are you chasing after the world and all it has
and all it tells you that you need?
Are you chasing after the image of others
or are you chasing hard after the Lord?
You know, you and I were created a glorified God.
He is our king.
We are to love him and obey him
and pursue him more than anything else in your life.
He shall reign one day as King of all.
But is he reigning right now in your heart today,
let's pray together
As you have your head bowed and eyes closed.
Just to make you aware again, we have men
and women who are here to pray for you.
They're on both sides of the auditorium.
If you have something you need prayed for today,
they would love to do that.
But right there in your chair, I want you to think
about the answer to some
of those questions I just asked you.
Are you going through a difficult challenge right now?
And are you complaining to God what's taken so long?
Or are you praying patiently like Hannah?
God, I just, I want to glorify you in all that I do.
Help me to be patient while I wait for you.
How are you doing? Obeying?
Are you struggling like Saul
and getting yourself into a bunch of trouble?
Change, change today,
rededicate your life to the Lord.
Lord, I want to obey you.
Whatever that is, I, I wanna take my hands off of my life
and open them up and do whatever it is
God you want me to do.
And Lord, I want to chase hard after you, like David.
Is that your prayer this morning?
Lord, you are on the throne today, not us.
You are on the throne today.
You reign over all things, including our lives.
We are in your hands. Do with us
as you please Lord.
It's our desire this morning to chase heart
after you, to glorify you with everything we have,
everything we have.
You be our number one. You be our king.
We love you Lord. Pray that you'll be pleased by the worship
in these next few minutes.
It's in Christ now we pray. Amen.
And would you stand with us as we continue to.